whoo and being a bit disingenuous in
order to prove the points absolutely no
I was traveling with Jeremy on the 11th
of August up to Newcastle for the
Gateshead hustings that evening we
boarded the train we walked all the way
through the Train and there weren't any
seats available and eventually when we
got to the far end of the Train you know
there were other people other passengers
unable to take seats who were already
sitting on the floor and in the
corridors and Jeremy being Jeremy joined
them on the floor got out his newspaper
and and you know and and sat down in the
same way that many other passengers were
doing on the train I guess we're quite
easy to challenge mr corbyn a Virgin
Trains would say that if you do look at
the CCTV footage there were clearly
seats that were available so he got up
he walked past a layer of emcee seats
they may have been reserved did the
video and then walked back down where
they were clearly seats that were
available no it's as I said I was there
with Jeremy when when this happened all
of the seats you know it might not be
clear in the CCTV footage but all of the
seats were taken either by people
sitting in them sometimes children
sitting in them whose heads would have
been lower than the level of the back of
the seats or baggage luggage that was
there reserving them for people some of
the pictures of their seats the front
they were clean no children on the seats
there were no bags on the seats I can
tell you we walked through through all
of the carriages and there weren't any
seats available they were all taken in
some way or another so that's why Jeremy
went down through all you know through
throughout the entire Train and then
ended up sitting down on the floor for
about 4045 minutes it was only later
when a very helpful train guard came and
notified us that there were some seats
that have become available I think a
family had been had upgraded into the
first-class section of the carriage so
the team were able to be seated that
happened about 4045 minutes into the
journey Virgin Trains will incite the
risk of their own reputation if they
weren't absolutely sure that they were
right and that's why they've released
this CCTV footage I mean I do think it's
it's curious that this is a train
journey that took place on the 11th of
August and yet Virgin Trains and Richard
Branson obviously you know people who
are opposed to Jeremy's policy of
bringing the Train the railways back
into public
ownership have waited until we are on
the second day into the labor leadership
election and the ballots dropped
yesterday lots of people are voting it
does seem strange that they are bringing
this up now the timing is odd you sing
they're lying all I'm saying is that I
was there on the train with Jeremy and
the version of events that the Virgin
Trains are putting forward is skewed you
know we were there
there weren't seats available when we
first got on the train that's why Jeremy
sat on the floor for the first part of
the journey for many people this will
appear like a stunt by jeremy corbyn's
team in order to make a point a stunt
that has backfire does this not tell us
about how the Corbin camp is in complete
disarray when it does come to trying to
make points getting it across to the
public at large not simply it wasn't a
stunt we were there on the train we
hadn't didn't have any intention
whatsoever on of making a social media
video I mean there are quite literally
trains every single day that are over
booked and cramped services if Jeremy
had wanted to find a cramped train it
wouldn't have been difficult for him to
do that that wasn't the case we were
travelling up to go to the Gateshead
hustings
you know it's supposed to be a nice
quiet journey where Jeremy was going to
be preparing she only if you were going
to do a campaign if you're going to do a
video you would find a train that was
completely full where there was no way
that the train company whereas Virgin
Trains or one of the other train
companies could come back and say no
that's simply not the case
you kind of get the impression that this
isn't the first time that this kind of
thing has backfired on mr corbyn and it
probably won't be the last now I don't
think there's any that was nothing
premeditated about it there was nothing
planned in advance about it we were
traveling up to Newcastle we were
intending to have a quiet journey on the
way up there the Train when we got on
there weren't any seats available it's
the Train that was going up to Edinburgh
so obviously with the festival on there
were lots and lots of people if you go
on to Jeremy's website or social media
channels you'll see video footage and
photographs of other people other
passengers who were also sitting on the
floor during that train journey this is
something that happened spur of the
moment it wasn't pre-planned and
therefore you know it's not something
that's backfired okay Emma Rees thank
you thank you very much